general topic yes thank you for the
introduction that title is very generic
for this type of workshop so I should
probably be a bit more precise so i will
talk about two types of problems vertex
partition problems and let x division
problems and we will obtain these
hardness results this is also kind of
nothing special for this talk by looking
at all reductions okay so maybe let's
start with a concrete problem we were
studying this monopolar recognition
problem it's a graph partition problem
where you're giving an undirected graph
and you want to partition the vertex set
in two parts a and b and one part should
induce an independent set and the other
part shouldn't use a disjoint union of
clicks also called classico up so in
this example cough you can do it right
so the green part these guys will be and
be and they induce the disjoint union of
kicks and the blue part is an
independent set okay so when we studied
this may be familiar with make point of
view we were looking at the so this is
an NPR problem as we this just as soon
we were looking at parameters such as
the number of clicks and this cluster
graph be okay and we obtained some fixed
parameter results nowadays if you come
up with an FPT I wouldn't you always
have to somehow give a good more or less
good lower bound that's amore justifies
that what you are doing is not too bad
not too far away from the optimum so we
will want to ring about lower bounds for
this parameter K okay so what's the
thing that you do you look at the known
hardness reduction and the hardness for
this monopolar recognition problems
actually the proof is by a very general
result which is about partitioning a
graph into graphs with two different
properties pie and fire so we have this
pie five partitioning problem the input
is a graph again we want to do partition
again and the one side should be
in the graph class pi and the other side
should be in a goth classify okay so in
our example pi is it being in any
pendant set and Phi is being a classic
laughs and there's this nice result that
if the two properties are hereditary so
closed under deleting vertices and also
closed under disjoint union of graphs
and they are not both being an
independent set and they are not both
being a kick then the problem is np-hard
right so these two things are needed to
somehow make sure that to coloring does
not become np-hard okay because this is
exactly two coloring or the recognizing
co bipartite grass and this property
essentially means that the forbidden sub
graphs are connected for this for both
properties and the reduction is actually
not too complicated it relies on the
fact that they are exist graphs that
have a unique partition into the two
parts okay so we we just looked at this
reduction and try to find whether it
gives us something for our problem and
it actually does so the reduction is
from a problem that they called p and q
hyper graph coloring so a given hyper
graph and you want to color it with two
colors and every edge of the hypergraph
should have P vertices of the color a
exactly p and the reduction has the nice
property that if this is your ipaq
laughs that you get as input then the
output graph has this many edges and
vertices also and we found that this P
and Q hyper graph coloring you can also
think of it as positive p and q set that
this has a type lower bound for the
running time so just just by looking at
this we immediately get this extension
or so which I got this without knowing
it that you cannot serve these problems
in 2 to the resolve and plus n time okay
so this was very nice but also a bit
frustrating because there's nothing we
had to do actually okay so but somehow
this inspired me to look at these
general hotness reductions again and I
looked at a class of problems that's
very well studied Piper text edition so
I'm giving a graph property pie and an
undirected graph and I can delete at
most the question is whether i can
delete at most K vertices from this
graph to obtain a graph that belongs to
PI so this includes vertex cover vertex
by parties asian many more feedback
vertex set a lot of these classic
problems okay and that's this very nice
classic result by Lewis and gonococcus
that for every I reddit Harry graph
property this problem is np-hard another
aim is pretty clear I guess we want to
somehow adapt this construction to show
also tight running time bounds and we
will assume for now that this graph
property pie contains all independent
sets ok so what does the reduction
looked like the reduction is from vertex
cover we can assume that it's from that
extra one sub cube across it's not
really important so
begin McGrath and we want to know can we
deleted most K vertices such a what
remains as an independent set okay and
what's the rough idea i will go bit more
into detail when i show the adoption you
replace the edges of this vertex cover
instance by small gadget graphs and
somehow you make sure that these gadget
graphs cannot appear too often and
graphs that have this property pie so do
you need to do something you need to
delete one of two vertices in this car
this gets you a graph g star and then
the next step is to add roughly theta of
n copies of this graph g star in the
reduction so the question is does it
imply these tight law bonds that we are
looking for and the answer is almost so
the the source problem is good even if
it's in sub cuba crafts then we have
this type running time lower bound but
adding these theta of n copies is too
much because you get theta of N squared
vertices in the Indian sensibly produce
and I said I suspect that this is I mean
at the time and the 80s it didn't make a
difference and it makes the proof a bit
more elegant the especially the
direction to show that whatever you do
for your pie vertex division problem
gives you a solution for the vertex
cover so the reverse part of the
equivalence proof ok so what's the idea
of the proof so I'm for if all the
forbidden sub graphs of the property are
by connected then it's actually quite
easy it's a bit more tricky if you have
cut vertices so this is to somehow deal
with these cat vertices jana [ __ ] has
introduced this notion of either
sequence which is just you look at a
graph and some vertex see in this graph
and you
just look at the connected components
that you get when you delete this vertex
and you order them by size and then the
sequence is just this string that you
get or this tablet that you get after
you have all of them okay and the IFS
sequence of the graph is just the
smallest sequence lexicographic order
that you get when you try all
possibilities for choosing this vertex C
ok so the in this example we choose C
like this then we get a 22 and in this
graph this would also be the correct
choice would be three two one what's
what's the use of this I have a sequence
it's if i delete i somehow i glue
together these these graphs and if i
make sure that i delete for each of
these larger connected components at
least one vertex then every connected
component that remains must have smaller
either sequences so if i start my gadget
graph with a graph that has very small F
a sequence I cannot produce other
forbidden bed forbidden subgraphs that's
the idea ok so for all construction we
need to be a slightly more precise let's
say so I introduced in order ring on the
grass that's basically just based on
this lexicographic ordering for the FI
sequence plus tiebreaking so isomorphic
graphs are the only ones that had the
same order in this position so this is
just to make some all the choice of the
forbidden sub graph that we make the
reduce unique in some sense ok and so
now how do we choose these forbidden and
you suck us in our construction so we
take one sub curve H so this is the
forbidden and your sub graph with some
connected components h1 is the one that
has this largest value largest as I see
wins if you want and we want to make
sure that or other forbidden induced
subgraphs contain at least one vertex
one connected component whose gamma
value is at least as large as this h1
and also there is none that contains
only these H once as Max gamma value
grass and then less h1 components as
this one ok so maybe to be slightly more
precise in from these three graphs I
would choose H ok this one has a this
thing as a larger IFI sequence then
these guys and this one has two of this
max I've with the max gamma value and
this one is only one yeah ok so this
one's a good choice ok so what does the
construction look like we assume that we
reduce from vertex couples in the
disease and this is my fixed graph H
that I use in the construction so at 2n
copies of these small guys here ok and
the idea is just if i delete the vertex
cover from this other graph somehow they
will remain a sufficient number of these
guys to somehow make sure that in the
end I would have to delete this guy
copies of this guy and I do the same for
for the small gamma value components and
now I had the situation that I might
have more than one with the largest come
avere you ok so for the for all except
for the last one I introduce exactly one
copy ok so in this case I have to so one
will get a disjoint copy and this one
will be used to somehow encode the
vertex color
instant so this is my vertex cover graph
that I want to analytics of instance
that I want to reduce it's actually not
larger than this one and this example
but this is not important so I will I
will build my gadget based on this so
first I introduce one vertex for each
vertex of this G and the small
components are some more glue to this
and then i use the largest component a
largest component after deleting these
catalytics to somehow one of the edges
right so this triangle corresponds to
this thing ok and now if I have vertex
cover here I can delete the
corresponding vertices here and here
this where they were all the connected
components that remains that smaller
karma value than what I had before and I
have a solution for the private
expedition problem so for the other
direction is actually a small problem
with the construction I'm not sure does
anyone see it already for the reverse
direction of the proof
so let's say my forbidden sup cough is
very simple it's the 2k too and okay so
this one I just make one disjoin copy
and this one is used for the vertex
cover instance let's say the vertex
cover instance is a triangle I would
take this and ok i will just build a
triangle and then the best thing to do
is actually delete this one all right so
it would tell me that my vertex cover
number is 1 for this cough but it's too
ok so this once more thing that we have
to do and this is actually just too so
the problem is if this h1 occurs more
than once we might delete their own
copies and the solution is to reduce
from a more restricted variant of this
vertex cover namely for one where we
have lar large girth so because if I
have large girth then whatever remains
in this from this vertex cover gadget it
doesn't have any cycles so the number of
h1 copies that I can care it's the same
as the one that I can I can delete by
removing in the kitchen side ok so what
this gives us is that for every
hereditary graph property that contains
all independent sets we cannot solve the
private exhibition problem into two
little off n plus m and this is true
even if the degree is bounded by some
constant let's say it depends on the
province and usurpers ok so
what if I doesn't contain all
independent sets so to exclude to to the
little of n time algorithms we can just
do the trick of complementing what we
have because every graph either contains
all independent sets or clicks if we go
up gruff class so this is fine and for
two to the little of em time algorithms
it doesn't work we cannot get this bond
and the point is very simple if it
doesn't contain all the independent sets
then there's some D times k1 that's
forbidden and there are two observations
that you need one is there cannot be
many high degree vertices it's very
obvious just from the what is it called
the handshaking lemma and we can also
include very few of these low degree
vertices into the graph that remains so
I can just do good force basically on
both sides and that's it ok I can do
slightly better if the property has the
additional the graph property has the
additional feature that there's some
high degree vertex in this graph so the
best example for this is click and you
can do basically the same as in this
click I wouldn't that is for example in
the exact exponential time algorithm
spoke by feel of women anteater kuch you
branch on low degree vertices and French
boot falls on the neighborhood and if
there are no such vertices then you can
just do boot falls on the total graph ok
so we have slightly better running time
for this and that's actually all I
really wanted to say about the results
so for the future and it would be nice
to actually have a similar dichotomy are
almost similar dicota be for these
vertex partition problems but the
situation seems to be a bit more
complicated
there because there are some cases that
are polynomial-time solvable it's I
think if one property is closed under
disjoint Union and the other one closed
on joins so it's the complement of
something that's close on a disjoint
Union another interesting thing would be
to have like more general hardness
results for these Kwazii hereditary
properties this is a property where you
cannot delete all the disease and stay
in a property but there exists one
vertex that you can delete and of course
this is this includes being connected so
it's not NP hard for for all properties
but would be nice there like a very
general statement saying like if I have
a quasi hereditary property it has also
some additional features then we have a
tight lower bond for this and maybe also
to look at this pie vertex deletion
problem in graph classes after dendias
talk the whole the same thing should
work for planar for the planar case
giving you two to the little or square
root and bounds for the text editing
problems in planar graphs because we
have this bond for vertex cover and it
would be maybe also nice at least I like
this type of research to somehow get
tighter bounds for the degree
constraints may be so generally this
bount that the degree the smallest
degree where the problem becomes hard is
three times the maximum degree of alpha
building subgraphs it's tight because in
vertex cover it's exactly degree three
that makes the problem heart but maybe
for some other types of properties we
can get better bonds okay and that's
question what is known about air
solution h deletion there is a there's a
reason paper on archive that shows a
very general lower bounds for edge
deletion I think there are no two to the
riddle of K time algorithm for almost
anything that we can think of but so
there's a there's a small difference
that the running gear the lower bounds
are for this switch is off
so here the bound is like little off m
which is some more stronger than this
the law of K for the edge deletions
because the number of edge deletions is
usually smaller smaller if you look at
these pies that have all independent
sets and so that's there's still some
way of I think improving on the archive
result but it's much more technical for
each modification problems I think that
this alpha peppers only treats of H free
edge deletion meaning like one removing
11 induced sub graph okay if they are
having any more general dichotomy for
for general property online okay nice I
haven't checked it out too closely you
only do you abstract this appears on our
life I think in september-october and
they are have complete or almost
complete the dichotomy 483 edge deletion
where when it's and complete that one in
cell formation don't remember I can I I
will find this paper i can send it to
you i think i'm some outdoors from india
but i don't remember any more questions
or remarks
if it's not the kinda nice tank all this